le jeune homme c'est le code barre ou la
carte d'identité précise de la canne à
sucre
le centre de recherche agronomique le
cirad la mise au grand jour une avancée
scientifique importante mais pour le ctc
est ce le centre technique de la canne
et du sucre
pas question d'aller plus loin et de
franchir le pas de la can transgénique
c'est vrai que c'est la connaissance du
génome qui permet après tellement le
connais d'éventuellement
jose apprentis sorciers ça donne ça
ouvre cette pente là mais ça ouvre aussi
d'autres portes clés tels que la
connaissance est ce qu en martinique
on pourrait un jour voir arriver des
canes 30 uniquement modifiés n'ont
actuellement martinique le choix était
fait d'utiliser des variétés d'origine
naturelle ils sont bien sûr issus de
l'hybridation mai et du fait du choix de
la martinique de firmes des produits de
qualité et qui a une aoc pour le rhum et
des indications géographiques pour le
sucre donc nous nous orientons pas vers
cela pour les planteurs le séquençage
permet de connaître les qualités des
faiblesses d'une canne mais le danger
pour les responsables de la sica cannes
union c'est la possibilité que cela
ouvre en matière de manipulation
moléculaire le cahier de charges de la
hausse et limite le tonnage de cannes
hectares à 120 tonnes
ça veut dire que même si on découvre des
variétés transgéniques qui nous
permettent d'avoir du tonnage on ne
pourra pas bénéficier du potentiel de
ces cas là nous pensons qu'il vaut mieux
garder nos spécificités
une canne naturel une cale qui pousse de
façon tout à fait durable et nous
n'avons aucun intérêt pour l'instant et
je pense pendant très longtemps à lécher
des cannes trois jeunes pour le galion
qui produit du sucre avec label
d'indication géographique la notion sans
ogm est un atout nous fournissons un
certificat 9e délivré par le centre
technique de la taille du sucre nous
travaillons aussi par exemple la
recherche des pesticides depuis plus de
10 ans doit cherchons faisant analyser
nous recherchons les métaux lourds d'une
centaine de molécules de rechercher
arsenic doit il faut qu'on puisse
montrer que nous avons un produit de
qualité
quand on est sur des petites histoires
comme celui là je pense que c'est par là
que nous pouvons nous battre ça j'y
passais par les volumes comme soins de
base par les prix à mon sens et par la
recherche de produits à haute valeur
qualité reconnu
les producteurs de rhums dispose d'une
aoc appellation d'origine contrôlée ne
veulent pas entendre parler de cannes
génétiquement modifiés ce serait une
hérésie une catastrophe pour la filière
un autre niveau déjà la france c'est
pratiquement le seul pays à lutter
contre les ogm depuis de longues années
et il est même le fer de lance justement
de la lutte contre les ogm
donc à ce niveau là y'a pas de problème
deuxièmement nous on ne peux t'y pays
donc utiliser des jeux à me faire nous
paraît inimaginable dans un deuxième
temps et puis surtout qu' on est un rom
d'appellation d'origine contrôlée
prévenir vaut mieux que guérir si ce
séquençage est unanimement salué pour
l'information qu'ils portent la filière
est cependant vent debout contre les
abus qui pourraient en découler des pays
comme le brésil ou l'indonésie cultive
déjà 10 canaux j m
attention à ce que cette découverte
ouvre pas la boîte de pandore